now you said uh you studied Nazi Germany
in in the 30s from a perspective of
maybe offensive
realism uh but just to look at the
Holocaust it's sometimes popular in
public discourse today to compare
certain things to the Holocaust people
have compared the Hamas attack on Israel
to the
Holocaust saying things like it's the
the biggest
attack on Jews since the Holocaust which
kind
of
implies that there's a comparison U
people have made that same comparison in
the other
direction what do you make of this
comparison is it comparable is it is the
use of the
Holocaust uh have any accuracy in
comparisons of modern day international
politics
is it possible that you could have
another
genocide yes and I would argue that what
you had in Rwanda was a
genocide right the Holocaust is not the
only
genocide I believe the word genocide is
used too Loosely
today uh and as you know lots of people
and I mean lots of people who are pro
Palestinian accuse the Israelis of
engaging in genocide side in Gaza I
think what the Israelis are doing in
Gaza uh represents a massacre I would
use that term given the number of
civilians that they've killed and the
fact that they've been indiscriminate in
terms of how they've been bombing Gaza
but I would not use the word
genocide uh for me a genocide is where
one side attempts to eliminate another
group from the Planet uh I think that
what happened with the Holocaust was
clearly a genocide and that the Germans
were bent uh on destroying all of
European jury and if they could have
gotten their hands on uh Jews outside of
Europe they would have murdered them as
well that's a genocide and I think with
the hutus and the tootsies you had a
similar situation uh I think with the
Turks and the Armenians during World War
I that was a genocide but I have a
rather narrow definition of what a
genocide is and I don't think there are
many cases that qualify as a genocide
the Holocaust certainly does okay
now what Hamas did doesn't even come
close to what happened to European jury
between let's say
1939 uh and 1945 although I date the
start of the Holocaust to 19 1941 if we
were you know looking at it closely but
let's just say 1939 when they invade
Poland 1939 to
1945 what must pales in comparison it's
hard to believe anybody would make that
argument right yes a lot of Jews died uh
but uh uh
hardly
uh hardly any compared to the number
that died uh you know at the hands of
the Germans I mean it just no parallel
at all uh and furthermore Hamas was in
no position to kill all of the Jews in
the Middle East just not not going to
happen yeah but there's also levels of
things you know using uh Germans using
uh human skin for lamps there's just
levels of evil in this world yes but you
don't see that with I mean that's not
what Hamas is doing I mean I I I want to
be very clear here I am not not
justifying the kill hamas's killing of
civilians okay not for one second but
I'm just saying and and and by the way
just to go to the Israelis and what
they're doing in Gaza right as I said to
you before I do believe that is a
massacre and I believe that's to be
condemned the killing of
civilians uh this is not legitimate
collateral damage they're directly
punishing the population but I would not
call that a genocide right and I would
not compare that to the Holocaust for
for one second I just want to be very
clear on
that